When a server receives
an HTTP request it returns
a response message to the client.
This response can contain
the information requested or
an error message if there was one.
Similarly to the HTTP request message,
the response consists of a message
header and optional body.
The first line of the header
is called the Status Line.
Followed by optional response headers.
The status line contains the HTTP
version, status code, and
a reason phrase that explains
the status code in English.
Here are some common status codes and
reason phrases.
The optional response headers take
the form of name value pairs,
similarly to their request
header counterparts.
the response message body contains
the data that the client requested.
If the client asked for a web page,
a sample response might
look something like this.
When you search the web, your web
browser takes care of creating HTTP
requests and
rendering responses onto your screen.
But as an API developer, there will
be times when you have to create and
dissect these messages yourself.
You'll learn some ways to
do this in the next video.